Hello, gamers.
Oh my god.
I just... Sorry.
I just realized...
So... Oh my gosh.
I was like, why does this sound louder...
Than I'm used to...
In my headphones.
Oh my god.
These are the same headphones that Matara was using for PT yesterday.
And there's a little knob on them that turns the volume up.
And I do that when I'm recording stuff.
So I can hear my voice better.
Without having to turn my voice up, up.
So that it's not peaking.
Which means Matara...
Turned the game up.
So that means the game was probably five times louder.
That's why she was so scared.
Oh my god.
No wonder she was so scared.
I literally... Because I was like, wow, my voice sounds really loud right now.
Because I have monitoring on so I can hear me talk.
Oh my gosh, sorry.
I literally... I just... I just...
Just now noticed this.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, sorry, hold on.
The audio is a little loud.
Too bad.
Try again, Ashes.
Also, happy belated birthday.
Oh man.
Did you already know about the wife ghost behind the character the whole time?
Yes, yes.
I've watched the things about like PT.
So I did know that.
That's why sometimes I'd be like, well, technically she's always there.
But yeah, yeah.
Anyway.
Yes.
Welcome to Dalmer.
The way that this game was described was like...
Kind of papers, please.
Oh, wait, you switched it.
You switched it, Ashes.
You got the hot dog this time.
Hot dog.
And like papers, please.
But also observation duty.
I don't know.
I just found it.
Sorry, I've been on such a horror streak recently.
I have been like non-stop horror games.
But I'm a ghost and I'm kind of always in the horror mood.
So I apologize.
Pampers, please.
That's so good.
Tis the season.
I do want to do for anyone curious.
Anybody who's been like, Mito, you should play Merry Gear Solid.
I do want to play that.
The Merry Gear Solid.
So I have that on the schedule for, I think, next week?
Week after?
Next week.
Mito, but I'm scared.
Don't be scared.
We're all here.
I'm here with you.
And I'm a ghost.
And then, that's why I'm also like...
I, you know, used to be someone that would watch a lot of Let's Plays of horror games.
I could always... I would never play them myself.
I would always be like, I'm too scared.
So now I've become... I feel like I've become so much more brave.
Because now I'm the person playing the horror games.
And then other people are like, I'm too scared.
I can't play it.
So now it's me.
I took that role.
Wow, Crasher!
Thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much!
The music in this though...
Oh my gosh, I have another Mitara story.
She left back home today.
This morning.
But I...
So last night, when we were...
When we were streaming...
We got some twin snake gummies.
You know, like the ones that are half...
Half sour, half sweet.
Right?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
I saw there was a second one too.
Yeah, I want to do them both.
Dr .Glorious, thank you for the 10 gifted.
And ViviCore, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Thank you guys!
Zephyx, welcome back!
Thank you.
Mervy, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Those sound great right now.
They're my favorite gummies ever.
They're so delicious.
If you've never had...
If you've never had twin snakes.
But I bought...
I bought a bag and she bought a bag.
Right?
So...
I had my own bag.
She had her own bag.
Last night...
She left the room for a second.
And came back with a bag of twin snakes.
And I was like...
Are those my twin snakes?
She was like, yeah.
I went and I stole your bag because I ate all of mine.
What?!
Those are my twin snakes!
And so...
She didn't finish the bag last night.
I left it on my desk here.
In my office, right?
I left them on my desk here in my office.
Which is where I stream.
And...
Then...
They were not finished.
I go to sleep.
I wake up this morning.
The bag is gone.
And it's empty.
And in the trash.
She was not sleeping in this room.
She was sleeping in the guest bedroom.
She came back into here.
To grab my bag of twin snakes.
And finish my bag.
And finish eating them.
And I even bought her bag.
I bought her bag and my bag.
I bought both of our bags.
And she ate both of them.
I got like three snakes.
Also Zenflex!
Thank you so much for the pin.
Congratulations on the new job!
Let's go!
Thank you.
No!
That should be your celebratory money.
Roach behavior.
Truly!
And then I have like a bowl of candy.
She kept eating at that.
And...
She also bought other candies.
At the store.
And she left the wrappers.
She actually cleaned up all the wrappers.
But there were just wrappers everywhere.
Of these little candies.
She is like a fiend.
This is actual roach behavior.
Boyfriend isn't home today?
Does boyfriend not like Vtubers?
Dump him.
We'll go out later in an hour.
High five wherever you go!
Thank you for the super chat.
Stream title says you can be an angle.
I agree you are an acute angle.
Maybe a little obtuse sometimes.
Are you sure you didn't eat them all in your sleep?
I'm positive.
Actually I didn't even realize that they were gone.
Like I left them on my desk.
And then I came back into here.
And I was like...
And then I see a trash bag.
And I see both wrappers in there.
And I was like...
And then I was like...
Both bags are in the trash!
And one of them I left on my desk!
So I know she ate it.
Playing Metal Gear for the first time today.
Whoop deers have so much fun.
Minto, it was my birthday yesterday.
I wanted to share some of my birthday money.
No!
Keep your birthday money!
I was too shy to ask for a birthday song yesterday.
I could have gotten one now.
You could have, Noxy!
You could have gotten one with the both of us.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Noxy!
Happy birthday!
But yeah, that was an eventful last couple of days.
It's nice and quiet now.
There's so much peace and tranquility in my afterlife now.
It's like I can finally breathe again.
I don't really breathe, but...
It's just like there's less negative energy in my myth cafe.
Thank you, of course!
Thank you!
AI summary says you're the one with the sweet tooth, Minto.
But yeah, but still, I have lots to keep me busy.
Lots of prep still for Phantom Thief concert and some other stuff I've been preparing.
I know I said something might be happening this week, but I believe it's actually might going to be happening early next week.
I apologize for the delay.
And if you don't know what I'm talking about, you'll have to just see when it all happens.
I didn't know it was Halloween.
Thanks for celebrating my birthday, Minto.
Wait!
Like your birthday was Halloween, Cooper?
Something is happening.
Something.
Something, something.
I heard Minto is a great dancer.
I like dancing.
I really do.
I haven't danced so much in a long time.
I'm a little rusty, so...
I'm nervous.
Finally started Astro Boy.
Oh, it's side play.
Astro's playroom.
I thought about doing playroom.
I've only done the first level.
I'm loving it already.
Thanks for inspiring me to start playing this.
Yeah!
Happy you could play.
So good.
I like dancing.
I just...
I don't know.
Can you guys already believe that it's December tomorrow?
That's crazy.
Sorry if you can hear me sipping on my tea.
That's crazy, right?
Haribo and Konami should do a Twin Snakes collab.
I agree.
This year has been very, very fast.
And for the VTuber sphere, I'll say.
For the VTuber world, it has been very, very eventful.
I hope everybody's doing okay.
It's been very, very eventful.
But, you know, I think VTubing is still a lot of fun.
And hopefully you still can enjoy it as a medium, if anything.
You know, kind of like if you're like, I enjoy this band.
I enjoy VTubing.
It's been wild.
2024 is a very tough year for VTubers.
Yeah.
But there's also been a lot of really great things that have happened, too.
So, you know.
I think, obviously, it's very easy to focus on the negative.
But there's been a lot of really awesome things that happened this year, too.
I think that, you know, we can...
You know, sad things might happen in 2025 as well.
But I think there will also be a lot of really awesome things that happen in 2025.
And we still have one more month to go.
And we have more events, even, in that month.
Like, you know, the Phantom Thief concert.
And that same weekend, even, is Hololive concert.
So, and whatever people have planned for Christmas and New Year.
Yeah.
Just, you know.
Go along with the ride.
Have fun with it.
My cat keeps opening my window.
Pa, stop it.
Stop opening.
Hold on.
She likes to watch the birds.
Pa, stop.
Stop it.
Okay, Mint's return is one of those positives.
I'm happy to be here.
I'm happy to be considered a positive.
Maybe.
She wants to eat them.
I know.
She, like, does that weird, like...
Have you ever...
For those who don't have birds... Sorry, not birds.
Cats.
When a cat sees, like, a bird or, like, a squirrel or something outside...
They do this thing where they go...
Yeah, the chirping noises.
They go...
It's so cute.
Sometimes she does it.
Butaro doesn't really do it so much.
I think because he's older, he doesn't really care about looking outside.
But she...
Because I think I got her from a shelter...
And all she did ever was, you know, she was inside a cage...
And all she could ever do was look outside.
I think she's obsessed with looking outside.
Back to MGSCon at boss level!
You gotta call me boss for now.
No.
There's only...
There's only room for one boss and one snake.
Got me an artist wife.
She draws lots of cute mint art.
Really?
That's the sound I make when Minto is on screen.
Shut up, Murphy!
She wants to eat those birds.
I know, it's so cute.
It's so cute.
Alright.
You guys ready to play Dollmare?
Again, I don't really know anything about this game.
So let's check it out.
So you can barely see the dolls scattered around.
Okay, like that maybe.
I can barely see them.
The lighting is kind of...
Oh, in this game, every playthrough is slightly different.
Many events in the game are not scripted.
Meaning that what you encounter is unique for...
Only for you!
Wow.
Stop it, Paz!
Stop opening my window, please!
I love you.
Let's stop, you're stinky.
God.
She lets in the silence.
Okay.
You will not be chased by a monster.
Nothing will scream or jump in your face.
But it is still a horror game.
Be prepared of being scared.
Are you ready to start working?
Okay, so I guess no...
No jump scares?
That's good to know at least, right?
With rent and bills piling up, I took a part-time job at an old toy factory.
People whisper about its shady reputation, but I don't care.
I just need the money.
Today is my first day.
I could...
I never could have imagined what's waiting for me inside.
Hold space.
Alright.
What if that's a lie?
I know, what if they lead you into like a false sense of...
Like...
False sense of security?
Still really dumb.
Sweet cheeks!
Okay.
What the hell was that?
Task, go to locker room and put on your uniform.
Can I run?
I'm so...
I'm so small!
I can barely...
I'm tiny!
Oh my gosh!
Locker room.
What else is here?
Assembly, generator, utility, exit.
Okay.
Hello, gamers!
Oh, nevermind.
Nice, we got water in here.
Does it seem dark to you?
Maybe it's dark because I have my windows open.
Is this my locker?
Alright.
Very good.
I'm sure we're looking right...
Stopper.
Okay.
Workshop, workshop, workshop.
Employee of the month.
That's gotta be me.
Is that your POV?
Canonical height?
Blah, blah, blah.
Look at this.
Even the light switches are ginormous.
Maybe we're actually a doll.
Gosh, it's really dark.
Fulfillment.
I will feel very fulfilled.
Repairs.
Gosh, it's really dark.
Place.
Oh.
Inspect.
Sweet Cheeks Factory.
OC Department.
Quality control...
Oh, sorry.
QC.
Quality Control Instructions.
Hello, everyone.
Today is my birthday.
I'm glad I get to spend a part of it watching you.
Happy birthday, Gingerbread Man!
Run, run, as fast as you can.
You can't catch me, I'm the Gingerbread Man.
And today is the Gingerbread Man's...
Wait.
Hold on.
Run, run, as fast as you...
Wait.
Run as fast as you can.
You can't catch me, I'm the Gingerbread Man.
And the Gingerbread Man has a special day.
Wait.
Has something to say.
Today is his happy birthday.
Happy birthday!
Gingerbread Man.
Run, run, as fast as you can.
You can't catch me, I'm the Gingerbread Man.
And the Gingerbread Man has something to say.
It's his happy birthday!
Okay.
I hope you like your special version.
Pick up a doll from the left conveyor belt.
Oh, conveyor.
Inspect it carefully.
If the doll passes the check, put it on the approval conveyor.
If there is something wrong with the doll, throw it in the disposal chute immediately.
Okay.
Keep doors closed.
Oh, oh, okay.
Okay.
I'm glad I saw that.
Why do they want that there though?
This door is closed.
Gosh, I can barely see it!
Guys, I'm gonna turn up the brightness a little bit more.
Nevermind.
Oh, here.
Even still!
Does that even do anything?
Epic settings.
Okay, so this is the disposal.
Okay.
Oh my god!
No,
I'm a good worker.
Perform quality checks.
Here we go.
Look carefully.
All body parts present.
All fingers present.
No dents.
They don't...
They are not a gamer.
Alright.
How many fingers are they supposed to have?
Five?
We're inspecting.
Five fingers.
Five toes.
This guy looks...
He's got a little bit of a bald spot.
Is that a defect?
Did the eyes move?
Oh, I can't tell.
No.
Looks fine to me.
There he goes.
Yay!
Missing an arm.
Defective!
Sayonara.
This is incredibly inefficient.
Oh my god.
Little grandpa doll.
Five.
One, two, three, four, five.
He's got his toes.
Yeah.
He looks like a little grandpa for real.
Is that supposed to be there?
The tail?
Yeah.
Good job guys.
Yes, Columbo?
I'm not... I'm not...
Okay.
Yeah.
I am.
Thank you, sir.
I'm not defective.
I'm scared of winning this game.
It says that there's no, like, nothing that jumps out, but like...
I'm scared.
This game has, like, such an atmosphere.
Five, five, five, five.
No tears.
No rips.
No head bumps.
No head dents, I guess.
A sweet little baby.
Wait, the hair?
Big dumpy check.
Does that count as a dent?
Because god damn!
That's a dent, baby!
I think it's a good dent.
Alright.
What's laughing at me?
Is it her?
Are you laughing at me?
Oh my god!
It gave me chills.
I don't know.
They're clowning on me.
Oh boy.
Oh god, that scared me, Roden.
I can't beat MGSV because of the cursed parasites.
You did.
You'll get it.
Alright, let's...
Four fingers, I mean five fingers, five fingers.
Five toes.
Hair...
It's missing a little bit of hair at the top, but...
Nothing like a good brush can't fix, you know?
Bald.
Slightly bald.
I don't think that's a defect, is it?
I think it's just how...
Maybe, I can't tell.
Is that the hairline?
I can't tell.
I think it's normal.
I wish they would give us more light in this room.
Okay.
Alright, little baby.
Defective.
He had a tear.
Don't like that.
Oh, he speaks.
He's got a dent.
Looks fine to me.
I don't think he'd appreciate it if I threw him out, you know?
This is just one of those, like...
Somebody was taking their anger out on the baby, you know?
But I don't want to get in trouble, so...
Oh no!
Another one!
Defective.
What's that rumbling?
Oh!
Oh, sorry.
I think I made the baby mad at me.
Yeah, it was one of Sid's from Toy Story's experiment.
That was just like a little demon baby.
Did I hear another one?
Nothing rumbling at me, okay.
Oh, okay, that's a light.
Gosh, I'm getting a little...
I'm getting a little paranoid, you guys.
I'm getting a little paranoid!
I'm scared!
What about this guy?
Stop.
You're under arrest for having the fattest dumpy in the west.
Gosh, how are you supposed to chop down any trees with that?
He's catching the logs in between there.
It's just so crazy.
Oh yeah, his fingers.
He's got enough fingers.
He's got enough toes.
His hair is good.
This is a perfectly normal baby child.
Dog.
Lumbergat.
This is our entirely unique...
Keep that close.
We're keeping all doors closed here.
I can't see over there.
It's so dark, I can't see!
Oh gosh, okay.
Kid looks fine.
Four fingers.
I mean, sorry, I keep counting the ones excluding the thumb, which is why I say...
Yeah, he's got crazy purple eyes.
This guy looks like he could be a VTuber.
Four fingers is not five.
But he has five fingers.
He has four fingers and one thumb.
Four fingers plus a thumb.
Oh my god!
Stop!
That scared me!
Boo!
Screw you, ducky!
Make ten correct sorts.
That's what the achievement I just got was.
Oh!
I think this doll...
has some...
sclera lenses in.
It's just cosplaying.
Obviously.
It's streaming.
I thought I smelled something.
What do you mean?
What do you mean by that?
Guys, we're killing it.
And by it, I mean little dolls.
We're killing defective dolls.
Does he have anything he wants to say?
What do you think he...
What do you think he wants to say?
I'm just going to keep throwing them away.
Just finished the...
Just finished TFAP.
Got the birthday cutscene.
Wait, does that mean it's your birthday?
Happy birthday!
Thank you, mundane.
Who you calling pinhead?
Oh yeah.
Five.
Looks normal to me.
See ya, normal.
Nice.
Alright, alright.
What is this curse game?
I know, right?
And it's interesting.
I'm like, none of it's scripted, so...
God, this bald spot is egregious.
We are the worst at... Look at this!
That's crazy!
I would... If I were a kid, I'd be pulling that out.
That would be fully... I would see that and be like, I gotta pull the rest out.
And it would become fully bald.
Give me my next baby.
No,
I don't like that.
Generator.
Oh, there's a baby doll!
Oh no.
Do a flip!
Is that...
This is just...
It's just oil.
It's a well-oiled machine, so there's just, you know, oil all around.
Someone's crying in there.
And there was a hand.
I thought it was a hand.
Or rather, when I first saw it, I thought it was a hand, and then I was like...
Oh, I don't think it's a hand.
I think it's...
I hear little footsteps.
This is so scary.
I hear it laughing.
I thought it was part of piping or something, but it was a hand.
Little pitter-patter.
Pitter-patter.
Okay, close the door.
Because I say close...
I'm doing it!
Okay.
What am I hearing?
Oh, the door is locked.
Interesting.
I got an achievement for completing a day with no errors.
Uh-oh.
Guys, I left this door open.
Oh no.
Wait, what about...
But I can keep playing.
Or, well, I say playing.
Working?
Does this count for overtime?
Where do I...when do I stop?
Oh, burning that midnight oil.
Do I go home?
He's not stopping me.
Hold on, let's see.
Is there actually like a...do I leave?
It says exit.
I'll go home.
Oh, I left all this stuff open.
I thought I heard something.
I go home in my uniform.
I'm really committed to the bit.
I wish there was a run, but there's not.
Sayonara, babies!
Okay.
Complete day one.
Oh, 300!
$320 in one day.
Wait, what is this?
Gift shop?
What's the motivator?
Wait, I want the jack-o'-lantern.
Let's get motivator.
And then we'll get the jack-o'-lantern tomorrow.
I just finished my first day at the factory.
There's something strange about this place.
Though I can't quite put my finger on it.
At least I got paid.
I keep telling myself tomorrow will be better, but deep down...
I'm not so sure anymore.
Yeah, easy, right?
Not like I'm impressed or anything.
Hello to you too.
Okay.
I'm on my way.
Wait, where's the... Oh, down here.
Oh, this is now utility and locker room.
Oh, don't like that.
Close the door.
Okay, close that.
What happens... Can you die in this game, I wonder?
Like if you don't close the doors, right?
Or will I die because I closed the door?
Oh my god.
What if I open it?
Oh, I had to.
I got a bucket.
Any baby leftovers, please leave.
Thank you.
Alright.
I think we're... I think we're good.
This place is absolutely cursed.
I would know.
Why is there already spooky music?
What is fulfillment anyway?
Also, it said I noticed...
I don't know if you guys saw, but it said that there was secret notes and I got none of them.
Put doll in a box, attach the order slip, send the... Oh no, I hate that.
Wait, I'm gonna be doing more work?
Okay.
Oh, I heard a drip.
And this door is still locked.
Okay.
Welcome to Amazon.
The big old workplace.
I wonder if we can find the secret notes now then.
You know, like...
Door is locked.
No repairs.
Okay.
This is gonna drive me insane.
I have improved the dolls.
Okay.
Wait, what is this?
Open box.
This is my motivation.
Success comes to those who don't ask for a break.
Tilt the doll, then bring it back to an upright position to activate the voice function.
Make sure the doll does not say anything inappropriate.
It's like those... What was it?
The Wicked dolls?
The Wicked Barbie dolls that had Wicked.com or whatever, but it actually...
No movement!
But it actually went to the naughty website.
Alright, our first little doll.
What are you gonna say to us?
I love you.
Memorable Med!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for the 50 gifted!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my god.
I feel like the guy we see in the lights is just a cardboard cutout.
Probably.
This looks good.
Oh, pajama baby.
Okay.
We got you a little onesie.
Oh yeah.
What?
I want to scream.
I
want to scream.
Sorry.
You can scream on your way down to garbage.
I'm gonna turn up the game a little bit just for you guys.
Nice.
I want, I want, I want, I want, I want, I want to scream.
Remix of the year?
That was very nice.
What does that mean?
I want ice cream.
I don't know if that's like an inappropriate thing for a doll to say, but it's not a...
It's rather, it's not an appropriate thing, but it's not inappropriate.
You know, like, it's kinda just weird to say.
I think it's fine.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Yellow eyes.
Lumberjack clothes.
Okay.
First, first one.
Yellow eyes.
Lumberjack clothes.
That was very nice.
Okay, what do I do with him?
What do I, what do I do with him?
Do I just place him?
Look at the pillar.
Put the doll in a box.
Like one of these?
Oh god, it's so dark.
And there's like secret notes around here, but I don't know how to find them.
I mean, that's why they're secret, but...
Oh, in utility.
Okay, okay.
In utility.
Do not, under any circumstances...
Do not...
The dolls...
Under any circumstances...
In the AmiAmi box, yeah, exactly.
Wait!
It changed!
To utility.
Hello, locker room.
I'll be seeing you later.
Okay, a box?
A box, a box?
Oh!
I got a note.
Why am I sorting dolls?
The director always knows when I've sorted them wrong.
Down to the slightest defect.
What's the point of me being here?
True though.
I found a thing, nice.
Oh, so thanks for the shoutout for Ace Combat 7.
You have the DLC missions, yeah.
Yeah, I got them, I got them too.
Yeah.
Do not.
I was actually so surprised at how much traction that...
That tweet got, honestly.
Because I was like...
Like, I tweeted about Ace Combat 7 being on sale.
Which is like a really good sale too.
But I was just so shocked at how many people were like...
Responded to it even.
Do I get the dolls in their fulfillment?
Or here?
Or not dolls, the boxes.
Maybe I just bring the doll to a box.
Maybe I pick them up and put them in one.
Oh gosh, something...
Oh my god, the shadow baby scared me.
Yeah, I don't cast a shadow, it's scary as hell.
What do I do with him?
In fulfillment.
Okay, let's just take him with us then.
The shadow baby.
Oh, one of these.
Okay, now place.
Put the doll inside.
Pick up.
Attach order slip.
Sorry, I'm trying to place it down.
There we go.
Where do I get the order slip from?
Maybe...
It's this piece of paper.
Did I just hear music?
Or am I crazy?
Printed paper.
Just crazy?
Okay.
Wait, both?
Okay, pick up.
Put inside.
Set.
Gosh, that was confusing.
Wait, did you guys hear music or not?
Crazy?
I was crazy, weren't you?
No?
It sounded almost like a...
What's the word?
Sweet cheeks!
Okay, this guy is fine.
Like an ice cream truck.
Alright, this doll is demonic, I can already tell.
Oh my god, also her shirt doesn't fit her.
Okay, I knew it.
I want to scream!
She just had a look in her eyes.
I could tell.
What about...
No movement.
Guys?
The disposal is gone.
Hello?
The trash can is gone.
She keeps staring at me.
Can
I go into repairs?
No?
She knows what I'm trying to do.
That was very nice.
I'm going to get a bad error though.
Try looking outside the room.
Oh my god.
Messed up!
Oh my gosh, it's back!
This game is wild.
Oh my god.
Sweet cheeks!
Okay, enough fingers.
Enough toes.
Seems fine to me.
That was not very nice.
There is a mod to add Minto?
What was that?
What was that sound?
What's happening?
What's going on?
Okay.
Green eyes, denim dress clothes should say hello.
What's going on?
Why was it getting so scary?
Ventilation.
Someone in the walls?
Lisa behind you.
What was that?
What did she just do?
I say send them all to that doll island in Mexico.
True!
That was not very nice.
I think blinking is a feature though, right?
Oh, another cursed doll.
What do you say?
You would be perfect if not.
Green eyes.
Kaneki-kun.
You would be perfect otherwise.
What if someone wants a demon doll?
We haven't had this one before.
That's like grey eyes.
Denim dress.
I love you.
Me talking to my cat, making sure she... Let me see.
Okay, she's alright.
I love you.
Okay, she seems alright.
Look at her fingers.
Yeah, I know.
I know you do.
I think she's good.
I don't want to do that.
What's over here anyway?
It's kind of bright.
Just a random light source.
Okay.
I really would prefer not to do that.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
One man job.
Seriously.
Oh my god, we are going back down here again.
Assembly is which way?
Oh, we can't close this door.
Interesting.
Baby backup!
Baby overload!
Oh my god, this is the thumbnail, isn't it?
Oh lordy lord.
This is where babies are made.
This is how babies are made, everybody.
Let's search for some notes real quick.
Before we... I wish they gave us a flashlight.
Something!
This is the baby boom.
Baby got back.
Look at all of them.
All these little babies.
I see no notes.
I don't like the music in here.
I just kind of want to leave.
Oh!
Sir?
Bossman?
What are you doing in here?
Mister?
Oh my god.
And he's gone.
Of course he is.
Gosh, I have to go... What was that?
Gosh, I don't like this at all.
It does say you won't be chased.
I think that's a note right there.
So, at least it gives you that kind of, you know...
What's the word?
Reassurance?
A few weeks in and I still haven't seen anyone else.
All I've got is this director's voice from the loudspeakers.
He's always watching.
I can feel it.
Does he ever leave?
So the notes are actually pretty easy to see.
Good to know.
This looks like we are about to get chased though.
Does it not?
Ok, just squeeze.
This looks like a room that you would have to like...
avoid...
stuff while running away.
You know what I mean?
Hey!
Get back in line!
Get back in line little baby!
You are going to mess up the whole assembly line!
This is why...
This is why our thing is jammed.
We have babies dancing on the assembly line.
Oh no!
Oh no.
Bit of a baby jam.
Baby jam.
Baby, baby, baby, baby, baby jam.
I want to what?
I want, I want, I want, I want, I want, I want, I want to scream.
I want ice cream.
Everything good now?
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
It's so creepy.
No delivery trucks.
No raw materials.
How does this place even work?
I looked for info about this place but found nothing.
Yet the dolls just keep coming.
I need to sort them.
But also...
Also...
Yeah.
Also, what do you mean you tried to look this place up?
How did you get the job then?
Very SCP-esque.
How does this even work?
Someone assembles the babies.
It will probably be my job later.
I'm going to make their job even more difficult.
I'm going to hide the babies.
There we go.
Scouted by the CEO.
Truly.
Oh, we can't even go down here.
Oh, we can't go up.
I was going to say, but we can go up.
No, we can not.
Close the door.
Alright, back to the...
Oh, everything is messed up.
The flying foolment.
The orky lemonco.
Oh my gosh, my mom at her house, she has like those...
She has candles that...
They are like individual candles, but they spell out home.
You know, each one is a letter.
Every time I go over, I mix it up.
I think that's just a ghost thing.
Now we have the ghost babies doing it too.
It's just a normal old ghost thing.
Yeah, like me-hole.
Wait, is this a denim dress?
Does this count?
I think this counts.
Denim dress, green eyes, says hello, right?
$300 plus a day for like 30 minutes of work, no ghost or demon would stop me.
I even start punching.
I think that's so fair.
Alright, let's go.
Do fulfillment.
How are the fingers?
Oh, true.
Thank you.
5, 5, 5.
Perfect.
Oh, things are okay again.
I like that this feels so random.
Like it is random and it feels like, you know, it's fun.
Okay, let me go get the paper.
Oh, I hate that I have to open and close the doors though.
It really freaks me out.
I feel like I'm gonna open the door at some point and there's gonna be something crazy.
What's in here?
No, pick up.
And send.
Cool.
I guess that was correct.
I can't tell.
What was that?
This game is making me paranoid for real.
Alright, next baby.
Can you bring the box with you?
Oh god!
Holy moly.
Do it again.
Garbage, garbage, garbage doll.
Guys, we are gonna make so much money I think of this round.
What you got?
I love you.
Oh, nevermind.
Cursed.
Cursed doll.
Oh man.
At least they are getting easier to spot, right?
Sweet cheeks.
Let's give it a second, see if she makes any sudden movements.
Yeah, I like the blue hair too.
It's fun.
Seems fine.
Is that Bulma?
Guys, I was so excited to see Goku.
This guy seriously looks like an old man.
Goku and Luffy and Pikachu.
In the Macy's Day Parade.
That was very nice.
It was very nice seeing them.
Yeah, I liked it a lot.
First Bulma, now Vegeta.
What, are we gonna get Trunks next?
Okay, seems fine.
We still haven't gotten an error.
Make 30 correct sorts.
That's what I got.
Master of the assembly line.
Okay, I like the twin tails.
I love you.
Missing fingers!
They cut a bit off.
I kinda wanna see what happens when you get one wrong, but...
I'm just too good at the game.
I think.
Wow, first time we got a...
First time we got a wrong...
fingers.
He seems fine.
See ya, kid.
His eyes glue.
Hey!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, she wasn't like that before.
That's crazy!
Wait!
Are you...me?
If only she had blue eyes, but the silver hair and everything.
That's kinda wild.
His bootleg Minto.
Let's see.
What do you say?
Seems fine.
All fingers and toes attached.
How long is this day?
What was that?
Our bucket!
Rude!
It is going in, right?
Gosh.
Kicking the bucket over here.
These dolls are inconvenient.
Do you think there is like a cult following for Sweet Cheeks dolls?
You know?
People are like, we love the Sweet Cheeks!
There is a lot of defective dolls.
There is a lot of defective dolls though.
I think they need to...
OK.
Thank you sir.
Oh look!
It won't let me use it now, but yesterday it let me use it.
I think we should leave the bucket, right?
The leak did not get solved.
I'm feeling very...what's the word?
Stanley parable with my bucket.
Don't come tomorrow.
I'm getting bullied?
Sorry.
Place.
Fine.
I'll just leave it here on the ground.
There is even blood in here.
That's a lot of spray paint.
The pay though.
I know, right?
Don't come tomorrow.
The kid is telling me not to come tomorrow.
Alright.
I'm gonna leave.
I sure hope no possessed dolls.
You know, I really need to eat.
Complete day 2.
Keep it rolling.
Production report.
Correct sorts.
3 out of 4.
$800.
Alright, let's get the jack-o-lantern.
Let's get the puzzle toy.
The mug.
Okay, that's all we can get.
We'll just go down the line.
I made it through another shift.
The dolls seem different today.
Their eyes.
I swear they followed me as I moved across the factory.
So proud of me for reaching such a high level of adequacy.
You mean accuracy.
Right?
Accuracy.
Good job Mito.
Here's a tiny bonus.
Oh, thank you!
They follow me as I move across the factory.
I keep telling myself it's all in my head, but this place is getting to me.
I can feel it.
I wonder... Sorry.
I wonder how many days there are.
Hello dolls!
I need to eat, so don't bother me please.
Dolls, I just... What the hell is that?
Oh, we have a different packaging now?
Alright.
Anything in this locker?
Still nothing in here.
Let's just turn on all the lights while we can.
Oh, the bucket is back in there.
I think we need to come grab it.
Oh shoot!
Oh my god, I've been leaving the doors open.
You guys, the doors!
I've been leaving the doors open!
Five nights at Dollhairs.
Everything fine in here?
OK.
Alright.
Let's go see all of our stuff that we bought.
I'm so excited.
Wow!
Don't throw it on the ground!
What was that?
Was that someone laughing?
Notice.
New employee.
Employee's name.
You left the locker open.
Oops.
What happens if the doors are open?
I don't know.
I've got some business to handle elsewhere, so I won't be around the factory today.
There's a new task for you.
We've got a bunch of dolls that have missing eyes, hands, legs or heads.
Throwing those into the trash from now on is prohibited.
You'll find all the info you need in the repair room behind you.
Don't mess up.
The director.
OK.
Our mug.
Rubik's cube.
Jack-o'-lantern!
Does it turn on?
Or...
Don't blink too often?
I'll try.
OK.
Nothing is open.
God, I thought that baby was staring at me.
Don't blink.
Uh...
Oh, wow.
It's a whole little baby workshop.
Oh, my God.
Oh, wow!
Pick up detail.
Oh, sorry.
No, no, no.
Please.
I got another note.
I found something in the archives.
This factory was famous for making dolls with incredible detail.
Perfect toys, they said.
But it was burned to the ground... 20 years ago.
Wee-woo!
OK.
I guess we'll just have to try this out once we get a bad baby.
Spooky!
There's a little bit of lore going on.
OK!
Of course, it's our first doll that we have to go repair.
Alright.
Let's... Gosh, so scary!
But dolls... I'm not... I wouldn't say that doll... Baby dolls really scare me so much.
The Hudson River, 20 years ago.
You're not going to clean up your peanuts?
What am I supposed to do with my peanuts?
What's that do?
Oh!
We gave her a whole new hairstyle!
This is the repair... Maybe I should read first.
If a doll is missing body parts, place it on the holding stand and attach the missing limbs.
If the doll is missing hair, there's a special tool behind the holding stand.
Use it to create new hair.
Do not put your head inside it.
It is not a hair dryer.
Someone tried once and it didn't end well.
Get back to work, the director.
This factory may be fake, but the money is 100% real.
Oh yeah, baby!
What color eye did she have?
Oh no, they're grey.
Ok, grey eye.
What was that?
Ok, and an arm.
I hope they don't mind the new hairstyle.
Unsuitable part?
What are you talking about?
Wait, no, no, no.
That's not what I meant.
So it's a left hand?
Oh, repair a doll for the first time.
It's a ninja.
Stop it.
Oh wait, we forgot to see what it says.
Ok.
See ya.
You're right, it's left.
You're right.
Ok, workout baby.
I love you.
Workout balding.
I think it's fine.
Oh wait, it's got all it's fingers and toes.
I think we're ok.
Now it says just repair if body parts missing.
They know we're too good for everything else.
You know what this game actually reminds me of?
A little bit.
Is mortuary assistant.
And that the events are random.
And it's a very quiet atmosphere.
You just do your job and freaky things happen.
Very mortuary assistant to me.
Hello.
I think it's fine.
It didn't do anything while I was holding it.
Help!
I guess it doesn't say anything.
It's shy.
I guess it wouldn't say anything because it's got no mouth to scream.
What kind of head do you want?
We'll give you whatever you want.
Here, I'll do the brown eyes since I have that one from earlier.
Brown eyes and some hair.
But the speaker is on the back.
That just suits you perfectly.
The comb over special.
He's like, you couldn't birth me with more hair?
Justin Bieber.
He's even got the Canadian fit.
It's perfect.
Oh my god!
God, that scared me.
She's got lifeless eyes.
Blue eyes like a doll's eyes.
Very scary.
Grandma.
Alright grandma, let's give you an arm.
I like how...
I like how I saw it spawn in.
That was kind of funny.
So it's this arm then.
Left hand.
Did you guys hear that?
Oh my god, that was so...
Oh, I got goosebumps everywhere.
Oh, I got absolute goosebumps everywhere.
I said the others...
It was very, very faint.
I said the others... something, something.
The others... It sounded like the others never left.
That was...
Get out of there.
That was not very nice.
I did not like that.
That was freaky.
That was so freaky.
That wasn't very nice.
I didn't like it at all.
Oh man.
It sounded like... I had to look over my shoulder.
It sounded like it didn't come from the game.
Ok, I think she's good.
Wait, let me see her fingers.
Ok, you're good.
Urgent?
Ok.
I heard another giggle.
Oh, it's the clown baby.
We have received a report about an unusual doll with claims that it moves on its own when unobserved.
If encountered, must be packaged and sent via the fulfillment room.
Immediately.
With this order slip attached.
Moves when unobserved, weathered appearance, single yellow eye.
Ok.
Urgent.
So it moves when unobserved.
This is actual SCP.
Peanut baby.
That was very nice.
So if the clothes are ripped, I guess then...
It looks like a stain on her shirt.
I guess this is fine though.
Is it actual?
Oh, what?
7-3?
It's gonna escape when Mint goes back for the slip.
No!
I'm gonna bring the box here.
Oh wait, but how would we...
How would we...
No!
I'll bring the box here.
I think it's fine.
Grandma!
This game is getting to me.
Toes, fingies, all good.
I love you.
She's staring at me though.
That's not normal.
You're not supposed to be looking at me!
What do
I do?
Get a box preemptively.
No, no, I said it was weathered.
Weathered appearance, single yellow eye.
Do you think it's okay?
Okay.
Good call everybody.
I love... That one blinks.
Don't blink so much.
Don't blink too often.
Dummy.
Stupid doll.
The one from the start of the game.
What one?
What?
I
love you.
This one seems fine.
Watch it like starts glitching out when I put it on the conveyor belt.
We found it!
It's so sweet.
It's eyes are really bugging out.
Hmm...
Okay.
Moves when unobserved.
Check if it moves?
How would I know?
I'm gonna lose it.
Okay, we got it.
Oh god.
Okay, come with me freaky, freako, freakazoid baby.
Okay, place you there.
Oh gosh, place...
The box.
Oh god, place the box.
Place the box.
Place you there.
Pick up box.
Place the box.
Okay, put doll inside.
Pick up.
Okay, nice.
Why lights be flickering?
You think it's still in here though, right?
It's still in there, right?
Because even...
Check if it's in the box.
Okay, hold on.
Now it's unobserved.
Schrodinger's doll.
You look inside the box.
Yeah, we are fine.
It's still in there.
I don't think the game is that cruel.
Okay, quantum doll.
If you are reading this, you have been trapped.
The fulfillment room door is shut and you can't get out, right?
Don't panic, there is a way out.
Squeeze into the lift shaft and press the dispatch button.
It took me to another place.
From where I have found a way back to my workplace.
I'm leaving this note in the shaft in case you get stuck too.
I hope you manage to escape and figure out what's going on.
If I haven't already.
The worker before you.
Wait, in here?
Get inside!
Find a way out.
I don't like this.
Oh my gosh!
Look up.
Wow!
I wonder if you can die in this game.
I can jump just a tiny bit.
I just realized.
There is this doorway too and then there is this here.
Oh gosh!
Okay.
Okay?
Oh my god.
What?
This is ridiculous.
This place is bigger than I thought.
Why was it built this way?
Why are there so many boxes?
Why can't I find an exit?
Why am I so huge all of a sudden?
Baby door.
Oh, I can go through.
Kei-chan.
Kei-chan led us astray.
What if Kei-chan is an evil doll?
Do you think I went the right way, guys?
I think...
Oh, what?
Wait, this is where I just came from.
Oh my god.
No way.
What?
This way for sure.
I don't like this.
Oh, it's so dark.
So that's the door I...
Where did I come from?
Okay, so we went through there.
Let's try the one that's blinking.
Maybe not.
Okay.
Wait, did I go this way before?
I
have to go through this one.
No!
I think... Wait, let's try upstairs again.
These ones?
We didn't really go through, right?
Spooky door.
Wait, this one has a note, so good thing we checked.
If you're reading this, you're still alive.
Hopefully.
But you might be trapped.
The doors here lead nowhere and the stairs bring you back to where you started.
There's no exit.
Follow the blinking light if you want to get out.
Just don't let them catch you?
The worker before you.
What do you mean by that?
Don't let what catch me?
Oh, I think that looped around.
Okay.
Okay guys, if I die...
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
The blinking light.
Blinking light, blinking light.
Which one is blinking?
I'm scared to drop down.
I'm scared.
PT Redux.
I don't want to redo.
Poor K-chan.
At least K-chan was nice enough to try and help us out.
Oh, over there.
Are we going the right way?
Oh gosh.
I hear something blinking, but I don't know where.
Maybe upstairs?
Yeah.
Which one?
This one?
Yeah.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, it's different this time.
Oh, we made it!
We made it!
Oh my gosh.
Footsteps.
I hear them all the time.
Sometimes I see the shadows in the hallway.
But I'm the only one here, except the director and the dolls.
Is it going to say like sprint to run or whatever?
Shift to sprint?
Oh shoot.
Oh,
this game is crazy.
Now it's like Little Nightmares vibes.
If I'm ever stuck in a pre-horror game...
Wait, what about K-chan?
Oh, I thought something was going to like come in.
We made it to...
Another... Wow.
Okay.
Locked?
I'm scared.
It's too quiet you guys.
Locked?
I'm glad I have my cat in my room with me.
I keep looking at her every couple of minutes to regain sanity.
Oh, we are in the utility.
He did tell me don't come to work tomorrow.
They told me and I didn't listen.
They told me don't come to work tomorrow.
But I didn't listen.
I'm the fool.
I heard the voice whispered again.
You shouldn't be here.
Creepy.
What was in the locker?
Oh, there was nothing in the locker.
It didn't seem like...
How do I know when the day is over?
Gosh, I'm so glad I have my mug and my toy and everything.
Okay, Justin Bieber.
This seems fine.
How many more days are there?
You're not gonna get paid for that unauthorized break.
Yeah, we just continue on.
The hustle never ends.
Oh, I think.
Oh my gosh, so cute though.
But that's definitely like...
Sweet cheeks.
That's like something wrong with your head.
I think that counts as a dent.
Oh my gosh.
I think that's the first dent that we've seen.
Something is breathing.
Do you guys hear it?
Anyway...
Wait, maybe...
Maybe I can't fix it.
Maybe I can't fix her.
I think because... Oh gosh, I don't like the lights.
I don't think I can fix her because it's a dent.
I think we have to throw her away.
Okay, so only missing parts we can fix.
Everything else we can't fix.
Alright, what do you have to say?
You look mighty possessed.
Is the door closed?
Yeah, I closed it.
That doesn't stop the dolls from opening it though.
Maybe I didn't close the door.
Oh my god.
Freaky.
Was that me?
Did I do that?
I thought you meant that door.
A knife is a safe and fun toy.
A knife is
a safe and fun toy.
That's my favorite remix.
A knife, a knife, a knife, a knife, a knife, a knife.
What was that?
It was like a high pitch.
Alright, Granny.
I love you.
You got all your toes, you got all your feet, you got all your arms.
You're not making any sudden movements?
A knife, a knife, a knife, a knife, a knife, a knife.
We are so good at this game.
To the repair!
I wanted to make sure there was no...
What's the word?
Any issues with the...
With the... Let's give him blue eyes.
Blue.
No issues with the clothes.
And the hairstyle.
Why can't the baby be bald?
I wonder.
Wouldn't someone want a maybe bald baby?
Check the voice.
What would you say if held upside down and shaken?
I'll have another.
The ominous lighting when they go.
No, no, no.
Oh my god, I didn't release Samara!
Oh my gosh, I was about to say wait seven days and she actually came out!
That's so cute.
Sadako!
Hello.
I think she's good.
She's got all her fingers and all her toes.
No, I tried to grab her.
It wouldn't let me.
How do we know when the day ends?
You think we can just leave?
Oh my gosh.
You think we can just leave whenever we want to?
Infinite money glitch.
Truly.
We don't have a supervisor.
What if I tried?
Oh gosh.
Stop it.
Stop it, you stinking... OK, so it's the right leg.
What's that clack?
Is that you?
Oh.
Chill out!
Please!
Unsuitable.
Nevermind.
I was wrong.
Please.
Oh, that's the hand.
That's why.
I'm stupid.
There we go.
I grabbed an arm.
That was very nice.
Having your arms ripped off was very nice.
Grandpa?
Because these kids look like...
These babies are like... They have that real baby adult...
Like, you know, how some babies really look like grandpas.
Some of these children really have that syndrome.
Middle aged man.
Alright, you got all your fingers, all your toes.
What did he say?
Hello!
She seems fine.
She's not moving at all.
One is going to say, I want another beer.
Have you guys seen those videos of the... I don't know what the alcohol is called.
I think it's Jepson's Malure.
Have you guys seen those videos of people trying to say the Jepson's Malure and then...
I'll have another.
It's basically... I don't know what it tastes like, but...
If you've had one, it's...
Oh!
Thank you!
I just heard something.
Basically, you try to say it, but it just tastes horrible.
So people are going, Jepson's Malure.
And then they drink it and then...
Oh no!
It's all messed up!
What do I do with you?
I'll dispose of it.
Into the bin.
Anyway, what was I saying?
Oh yeah, it just tastes so horrible.
People are just like, Jepson's Malure.
And then they take it and they are like...
I can't say it because it just tastes so horrible.
I'm really curious though, but it sounds like it's actually awful.
I use Malure for bets at festivals.
No way!
Dang it, I still missed a secret note.
Also, it goes so fast, I don't even have time to...
Yay!
We bought all the stuff!
Big spender.
Buy all items in the gift shop.
What?
It says...
The achievement had a typo.
It said gift shop.
Shot instead of gift shop.
Something is pulling me in.
Why do I keep coming back?
Maybe it's not a typo.
The gift shot.
What if I leave?
I'm not late!
Am I?
I'm late!
Ew!
It said are you scared of me?
Oh my gosh, we just got here.
Can you chill?
Can you please calm down with the spookiness right now?
I know, but the money is too good honestly.
The money is too good for me to want to leave.
Stinking ghosts.
Let's see.
We are fashionably late.
Anything in here?
Nope.
Here?
Just a bucket.
I don't think we need anymore.
Another day, another doll, another dollar.
What else you have for me today Mr. Director?
That doll looked at me.
My face, my feet.
That doll looked like me!
My face, my features, everything.
I threw it into the disposal.
The director didn't comment on it.
Freaky.
Oh wow!
OK.
Wait, what's a foreign object?
Place the doll inside the x-ray machine.
Press one of the green buttons to make a shot.
Use the same buttons to rotate the doll.
Oh, like a screenshot.
OK, got it.
Like a picture.
Make sure there are no foreign objects inside the doll.
Teddy!
Fidget spinner!
I don't even know what I bought.
I just bought everything.
What's this?
I will contact you today.
The director must not notice anything.
Don't be scared K.
K for cactus.
I just heard something go pew pew again.
Someone's here.
We got another little doll about...
Wait, how is K going to... How is K going to contact us?
OK.
Alright, enter!
And then what do I do?
Sorry, I forgot again.
Press on the green button.
It has a heart?
Is that a foreign object?
Are you
supposed to have that?
No foreign objects inside.
OK.
Alright, they are not supposed to have hearts.
Human hearts.
How am I supposed to... I'm so freaked out.
When is K going to contact us?
Alright, what are you saying?
Alright, yes it was.
Place the doll.
Alright, so...
This guy's got nothing inside him.
Not even a brain.
Stupid dummy doll.
Alright.
Let's go.
You threw away a human heart.
That's to the black market.
Don't talk to dolls.
They lie.
What do you say?
Sweet cheeks?
That doesn't seem like a lie.
These guys do have sweet cheeks.
Oh my god!
This game is really fun for how simple it is.
That was very nice.
I don't think that was.
OK, wait.
Anything inside it's mouth?
I don't think so.
The scratchy sounds you sometimes hear is from your task in the top left changing.
Oh, I see.
Thank you.
Thank you Fluffy.
You solved the mystery.
The clown doll looked like...
So funny.
Very funny.
They lie.
He has teeth in him!
Where did that come from?
Does K stand for chair?
Take a seat.
I'm squatting.
Clown?
You think I threw him away?
Wait, was K the clown and I threw him away?
Wait, where did that note go anyway?
Wait, the note that I...
That K left, it's gone.
Wait!
OK, we got to go put a little here.
Let's investigate you first.
OK, nothing inside.
What note?
There was a blue note that K left that said I will come and don't be scared or whatever.
Under the thing?
What thing?
Under this?
No?
The chair is gone.
Oh yeah, you're right!
Oh my gosh.
I didn't even notice.
Freaky.
Gosh, this room.
Oh, there is another note.
Hold on.
K, what are you trying to tell me?
Something is changing in me.
I don't feel right.
My reflection in the mirror doesn't look like me anymore.
The director knows he is doing this.
All the notes that K leaves are also yellow, but the one that K left on the monitor was blue.
I don't think it's actually K.
I don't think it's actually K, you guys.
Maybe K has changed beyond recognition.
Do
you think the dolls are former workers?
Maybe.
Wow, how dapper.
Are you K?
I am K, destroyer of worlds.
OK, seems fine.
What?
Maybe they got a new notepad.
I somewhat doubt it.
Sorry, I'm just looking around.
I'm on lookout.
That one is super haunted.
He wasn't.
He was just fine.
Oh, another guy is super dapper.
I don't like when they turn off the lights.
But I'm glad we had our jack-o-lantern.
He was very bright.
Haunted with style.
And nothing inside of there.
Oh my god.
Stop, please!
Stop turning off the lights!
It's my least favorite thing!
Oh, there is a note over there.
No one knows about the factory.
No one even heard about it.
These dolls aren't being sold anywhere.
Sweet cheeks, is this place even real?
Oh my god, stop!
Guys, they keep turning off the light.
And the disposal is gone again.
Oh my god.
This guy was fine though.
I think.
I don't know.
As soon as I got you, everything bad happened.
Get out of my sight.
What?
Wait, what was it?
Sorry, sir.
What did I... What was the issue?
I did the x-ray, did I not?
He had nothing in there.
It wasn't.
Not very nice at all.
He was turning off the lights.
Every time I grabbed him, it was turning off the lights, I think.
Oh, the disposal machine is gone.
Wait, I think someone mentioned that.
Yeah, I think it's outside probably.
Oh my god, demon baby.
He's gone.
Be gone.
I have no time for your nonsense.
I have no time for demon nonsense, OK?
I guess she's fine.
Place.
What?
Oh no.
Oh guys, I'm not gonna be... You know what?
I don't need to make so much money anyway, because...
I bought everything that I wanted, but I'm getting weak.
Alright, too many fingers.
Got it.
Sorry, sir.
You shouldn't have come back.
Oh my god, what just happened?
It transported me!
Oh my god.
This game is so...
Oh no, that's my cactus.
You think I can leave?
Sweet cheeks.
Doesn't seem like it does anything.
It's not turning off lights.
It's being just a doll.
Fingers?
Oh, thank you.
Four, four...
OK, I mean five and five.
You know what I mean.
I wanna go home.
Anyway...
Is she doing that?
I think it's her.
I can't tell if those are my footsteps and I just never heard them before or if it's somebody else's.
Hello?
I don't know if it's cursed or if that was just a little funky moment, you know?
A little prank.
A little funny prank, right?
I have spiders.
Because I picked her up again and nothing happened, so...
I think she's fine, right?
Right?
She's probably OK.
A little funny haha.
Well, I guess we'll see.
Yeah!
See?
Everything's fine.
She's got a bug in her.
Matara can't leave this place.
Alright.
Nice.
Sweet cheeks.
Let me check her fingers.
Alright.
That was also, I think, our first one.
The one that I got wrong initially.
I think that was our first one wrong with too many fingers.
You know?
I never had one with too many fingers.
We had the ones that were missing fingers, but...
I like how all these parts just hang around here.
Let's just say...
Hair color change?
What?
I don't think so.
Is that a doll behind the screen?
Here?
I don't see anything.
Sweet cheeks.
What's that?
Disposal.
That's what that is.
Yeah, that's where I was going to go.
Hide in the locker room.
That's where I was going to go.
Okay.
What if I yeeted him?
He's a ginger.
Should we trust him?
Yeah?
Sorry, I went to the bathroom.
Sorry.
Do we trust him?
A few days?
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh no.
I don't know.
I don't trust the director, but I don't think I trust him either.
Right?
I wonder if there are multiple endings.
Actually, you are right.
There are multiple endings.
There are two endings.
Let's just trust him for now and if we're done, we're done.
Potty!
Sorry.
One doll, green eyes.
Alright.
Easy.
One doll, green eyes.
We can do that.
Look at that.
Immediate.
Is she possessed?
Okay, she doesn't say bad things.
She has no foreign objects in her?
I think we're fine.
Right?
I'll go get the box.
Fingers?
Oh, thank you.
Yeah, let me check the fingers.
Five, five.
Yeah, no extra fingers inside her.
I can't believe we just saw K and he spoke to us.
That was kind of wild.
That was kind of ridiculous.
You'll never be alone again.
The whispers are starting to get way more frequent.
I gotta up my haunting game.
Seriously.
They're so good at this.
I had a feeling K would be a doll.
Yeah, me too.
I just, you know...
I don't know what I expected to happen though.
I'm not sure what I expected to happen.
So, I guess to get both endings...
Maybe you have to...
Like, yeet him.
I don't know.
But I don't know if I'm willing to go through the whole game again just to get the second ending.
You know what I mean?
Are you haunted?
Signs say don't talk to the dolls.
They lie.
That is true.
And honestly, if we were bad guys, or rather if the director was the bad guy...
Why would he 1.
Pay me and 2.
Why would he want to dispose of the haunted dolls?
You know?
You should unironically do a haunting ASMR.
Maybe.
That was very nice.
10 hours of silence sometimes interrupted by haunting Minto ASMR.
Oh, sorry.
Fingers.
I think we're good.
Noise.
Oh my god.
This one is so cute.
I love this one.
This one is fun.
I want to give him heterochromia.
No.
Guys, I can't see.
I'm scared.
God.
Oh my god.
I liked you.
I also heard laughing.
I think we have a clown amongst us.
Or maybe not.
I don't know.
The games aren't lagging though.
Oh gosh.
It was not very nice.
Do you have anything else?
Any extra toes?
No rips and tears?
A clown you say.
I think it's fine.
This one is...
This one is messed up, but I don't think we repair this, right?
Yeah, we just throw them away.
Yeah, it's too much work.
We can replace parts, but it's too much work to pull them apart.
Sweet cheeks.
Young Sheldon.
We get so much variety out of this guy.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, that's our button.
It moved all the way over here.
That's funny.
The anomalies, I suppose you call them, are so funny in this game.
Alright, we got our little dapper bunch again.
I feel like I'm hearing something, but maybe not.
I don't know.
Oh, he's got a heart.
No foreign objects.
Did he do that right?
Now it's hard to tell who's doing what.
Those look like windows, but does that mean we...
We have the night shift?
Thank you, director.
Go home.
Will it let me in?
Yeah, it was only that first day that we could have, I guess, taken advantage of the extra...
The others never left, yeah.
OK, I'm going home.
We didn't find any notes this time really, but that's OK.
That's fine.
I think we're still getting the lore.
Day 4 complete.
We made some errors, you guys.
Oh, but we only lost $60.
This is easy money.
Gosh, we can leave now.
We can leave now.
We can go find another job.
I saw him today, or what's left of him.
The worker before me, the one who disappeared.
He's still here, but he's a doll now.
He spoke to me, said the director did this to him, that everything is a lie, and I'm next.
I should have left while I had the chance, but it's too late now.
It all started in the factory, and it can only end here.
This company must have the slowest output in the world.
It's because Day 5?
The sign is crooked.
We take our time with quality control so that we can...
Everything is whispering at me now.
So we can ensure the highest quality.
If all else perished and he remained, I will still continue to be...
And if all else remained and he were annihilated, the universe would turn to a mighty straight...
Why is it so ominous?
What's this?
I remember my hands, flesh and bone.
Now they're different.
They don't ache.
They don't move the same.
I wonder if you've noticed it yet.
You will.
Niels, happy birthday!
Can I have a birthday smooch?
Just a little kiss on the cheek.
A tiny little peck.
You sure are asking for a lot.
Thank you for the Akusupa!
Happy birthday!
Sorry I couldn't sing happy birthday to you.
Oh, hold on.
I keep hearing a bunch of noises going on.
Oh, it's the lights flickering.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Niels!
How do I say your last name?
I'm just going to say Niels.
Niels!
Happy birthday to you!
Another day, another dollar, another doll hair.
What is...
Oh wow!
Okay!
Wow!
We are...
Beware of something.
We are expediting the problems with these dolls.
It's crazy.
Sweet cheeks!
Why are all the lights flickering so much?
Okay, he's got nothing in there.
How do I... Oh, place.
Place him.
He seems fine to me.
I like how it's like no radiation.
Do I just... That's it?
And then let's check his toes.
Oh my god.
They have a nice little tune going on though.
I think he's fine.
Examine him while he's in there.
Oh my gosh!
He's got... Sweet cheeks!
Oh!
He's got like a mark of... Okay.
Not sweet cheeks.
Mark of the devil.
Alrighty.
I mark.
I like the little angel outfit.
It's cute.
Okay, what do you say?
Hello!
I don't like... I really don't like the blinking.
I really... Oh gosh.
I really don't like the blinking now.
Okay.
Seems fine.
It's kind of hard to... This one is hardest I think because...
You have to have it at like the correct, you know.
Alright.
Oh wait, she's fine.
What?
My sheets do the same thing under UV.
What do you mean by...
Oh gosh, this game.
What do you mean by that?
If you encounter a doll with steel nails embedded in it, treat it as an extremely dangerous object.
This doll poses a serious threat and may interfere with equipment or cause harm.
Dispose this doll immediately by any means necessary.
Exercise caution during removal to prevent further risk to yourself or the machinery.
Report the incident to your supervisor as soon as the doll is disposed of, ensuring that no additional hazards remain in the area.
Yeah, we had that doll earlier.
Hello.
We had that doll earlier.
I think she's not good.
That means like some children have been getting like...
Some kid got this doll and then probably like a black light for Christmas and was just like...
And then just sees like all this blood splatter all over their doll.
Do you?
Do you actually?
Oh wait, hold on.
Or the marking is bad though.
Well, it means it's dirty at least, right?
It's just got nastiness all over it.
Right?
I think she's fine.
I love you.
Come here little doll.
No rips, no tears, no extra fingers.
Alright, into the x-ray.
Nothing.
Into the UV.
Oh gosh, she ages.
She like becomes a real grandma.
Okay.
Sorry.
I don't know why I did that.
I'm so sorry.
Yeah, I'm on autopilot.
Parent of a child with special needs orders a personalized doll with quite unique features and interesting looking shapes.
Purple eyes and says hello.
Okay.
Literally on autopilot.
Oh my gosh.
She was too perfect.
She had to be disposed of.
That's a first.
Stop oozing ectoplasm all over the dolls.
I'm sorry.
It's just how my hands are.
Emo doll.
Crawling.
I'm scared.
Okay, seems fine.
Nice.
Oh gosh.
Seems fine.
National warning.
Did you buy a Minto doll?
You may have to check her under her dress.
No!
Don't do that.
That's actually...
I was really embarrassed to...
Wait, what did it say?
Purple eyes and gray hair.
Well, this one has purple eyes.
Let's see.
Dang it, it does not say hello.
I was embarrassed if I got like the dolls where you can change the clothes and stuff.
So I purposefully got one where you could change the clothes.
Okay, into the disposal.
Stop blinking please.
I don't like this.
Why was it day 5 question mark even?
Oh, there is the demon baby.
I heard him.
Go away demon.
Just balding.
Purple eyes and says hello!
Oh my gosh.
Purple eyes says hello.
Nothing inside.
Crawling in my skin.
Hello!
Thank you so much for the...
My love for Heathcliff resembles the eternal rocks beneath.
A source of invisible delight, but necessary.
Heathcliff.
Is that like the...
What are those?
The chocolate bars?
Alright, order number 1.
Let's go get the box.
I didn't hear that one.
Sorry, I'm too fast for you ghosts.
You're gonna have to speak up.
You're gonna have to speak up because I'm moving fast and you're not whispering loud enough.
The light is getting pretty craziness.
I wish I could pick up more than one thing at a time.
It's a withering heights quote.
You little bitch.
Get out of my sight.
You!
Get out of here.
Thank you.
I'm sick of being clowned on.
I'm trying to do my job here.
I'm just trying to be an honest worker.
I do wonder what happens if you keep the doors open though.
Gosh, we can continue.
A knife.
Oh no.
Is that you?
No.
I think the lights just turned off.
A knife.
I hate this room because this guy is always clicking.
Demon baby?
The demon baby is so funny.
All you just hear is...
What if I...oh.
What if I made this doll to become the order, you know?
What hair are we going to get?
Cute!
Actually I love that.
How miraculous ladybug of you.
What do you say?
Sweet cheeks.
That's what I'm going to say from now on instead of thank you.
What's your name, Miku?
What do you say?
Hello.
What's inside of you?
Nothing.
What's on you?
Nothing?
Okay.
I think she's good.
Sweet cheeks.
Noice.
What about you?
This guy looks haunted.
There is something wrong with him.
Oh my god.
What's inside you?
It doesn't show up as anything, but do you see his mouth?
That's crazy.
Radioactive!
Alright.
No rips, no tears.
No extra fingers.
Sweet cheeks.
To the garbage.
Gosh.
No.
No, I don't like that.
Oh my god.
Find all dolls?
What?
I don't like this.
I hear one laughing.
Where are you laughing from?
Oh right here.
What do I do with you?
Doll found.
Okay.
Oh there is a note.
The air feels thicker, heavier, like it's pressing down on me.
I saw myself in a reflection.
For a second I didn't recognize my own face.
Was it ever mine?
Yeah, I wanted a treasure.
Let's check in here.
I think I just heard something whisper, run.
Creepy.
I don't hear any giggling, so not in here.
Is there like a secret time limit?
Oh my god.
No, the door is open.
No, we hate that.
Oh, there is one.
Yikes.
It's kind of cute.
They are kind of cute, I'm not going to lie.
Can you fix me?
Said one of the dolls, or the whispers.
That scared me though.
The megaphone upstairs, or above the door.
Freaked me out.
Okay, you think I'm going to have to go downstairs?
Are you scared?
Why is this open then?
Oh snap!
Oh, it wasn't me!
I'm sorry!
This is messed up!
This is so messed up!
I'm a baritone, but a tenor when you play.
Spooky game.
Did something just fart?
Oh, I think it was my cat.
Did you guys hear that in the game?
That was me, sorry.
Paz!
Paz, was that you?
No.
She was just stretching.
Did you guys hear it, or am I crazy?
I guess I'll smell it in a second.
Oh no.
This game said nothing scary would happen.
They were like, don't worry.
Nothing will jump out at you.
I guess that's true, technically.
Oh, you're good.
What are you doing Paz?
Are you waking up?
Hold on, I'm going to say hello to her.
Paz, what are you doing girl?
What are you doing baby girl?
Yeah, you're so cute.
You're so sweet.
My little stinky cat.
Next, we got to fix this guy.
I'm assuming the ones that are broken are like... fine.
You know, like they're not possessed.
You just have to fix them.
I'm assuming.
Is that door downstairs still open?
I don't know.
I don't know why it was open to begin with.
Maybe... Oh my gosh, it is.
But it wouldn't let me shut it, you know.
I'm wondering if it opens just in case...
Shut up!
Yeah, see, it won't let me shut it.
Oh my god, we can go in here and stuff though?
It's kind of weird that we can... Wait, why can't we go down here actually in the first place?
Exit?
Oh, oh, like...
Why are we allowed down here?
I just brought this baby doll with me.
Huh.
Exploration time.
Okay, I'm taking him with me.
This is my hostage.
This is my hostage, so...
Probably more notes.
I imagine that the dolls...
The, uh, what's it called?
Girlies?
That were hiding around probably could hide down here.
It's RNG, and so they just open it up just in case.
Just in case, so you don't get softlocked, you know?
The generator is running and the sound of it freaked me out.
Oh, there is a note!
They whispering.
They're telling me secrets.
They told me about him.
They told me about you.
Okay, I don't think K is okay anymore, you guys.
Guys, I don't think K is okay anymore.
I think K is, uh, lost a little bit.
K was never okay.
He used to be okay, now he's just K.
Now he's just K.
Oh, another one.
I'm becoming one of them.
I can't stop it.
I don't have much time left.
If you're reading this, it's too late for you too!
Uh...
I don't think we're K either.
Uh-oh.
We might be in trouble.
The others never left.
The others are all dolls.
How many people worked at this factory?
Okay, let's give you an eyeball.
You are getting a green eyeball.
Alright.
And we checked.
We checked his UV and his X-ray.
He says hello.
He's all good.
We walked around with him a ton.
Wait, what do you mean I missed one?
Stop!
I missed one what?
A doll?
I heard the Satan baby.
He's probably around.
Just, you know...
Let him be.
They silenced you.
And so will I.
Nice.
Creepy.
Fingers, hands, toes.
I love you.
Nothing inside that brain of yours.
Okay.
We haven't gotten the nail doll.
Well, we actually technically got him in the first day.
Which was probably...
I imagine that's scripted, right?
I imagine that's scripted.
I know this game says that there's nothing scripted in here.
But there's some scripted things.
Especially for your first day.
Alright, let's see.
A couple adopting a child from overseas requests a doll that reflects the child's cultural heritage.
They hope it will help the child feel connected to their new home.
Do we need to get the bucket?
Anyway, that's a hazard.
I think this... Oh, nevermind.
It's gone now.
Anyway, blue eyes.
I like that these all have very descriptive reasons.
They can't just request a doll for any whatever reason that they want.
They have to have a really...
Descriptive...
Everything.
Sweet freaks.
Sweet cheeks.
Yeah, I know.
I heard you.
Sounds... Looks good to me.
Boo boo boo.
I wonder how many... Oh, wow!
We have a mutant?
Hey, someone would want this one.
Literal third leg.
It was an arm!
Oh!
This is the loading screen.
Or like the menu.
That's fun.
There's so many... I wonder how many like...
Oh, okay.
Nevermind.
Stop interrupting me, game!
I wonder how many more like...
Not anomalies, but like little occurrences that happen in the rooms.
There are... There seems to be a ton.
That we've gotten.
And of like a decent variety too, you know?
Blue eyes!
You're right!
Thank you.
I completely forgot about it, I'll be honest.
Blue eyes!
Okay.
So, just blue eyes.
Alright, nice.
Yeah, a lot of variations.
Lots and lots.
Okay, let's go bring the box in.
I heard something laugh.
I think that means there's...
I think that means there's a clown around.
Oh, there he is!
I wonder if it's the doll boxes talking.
I think so.
I think that's why it talks every time I...
Every time I leave...
Like this room, like every time I walk by, some of the dolls are talking to me.
Hmm.
Okay.
Get in there.
Box it up.
And pick up.
And off we go.
Because now it's happening...
Now it's happening literally every time I leave the door.
Like I leave the room.
So...
It's very frequent.
Very, very frequent.
Little whispers.
The first time though really got me.
First time though was so, so freaky.
Okay.
A little angel.
Do you have anything inside of you?
No bugs?
Okay.
Nothing on you either?
That was very nice.
This one also has blue eyes.
No fingers?
No.
Yeah!
You scared me!
You made me think!
I messed up.
Okay.
I do need to look at the fingers though.
What was that?
I love the pumpkin outfit.
Oh wait.
Fingies?
Maybe they said no fingers.
As in like you didn't check the fingers.
Which that was true.
I didn't check the fingers.
I love you.
Guys I have to go to the bathroom.
Has it been two hours?
Yep it has.
Oh my god.
This thing...
It looked like a tiny head.
Like a tiny head of a person.
Oh my god!
Oh no, this guy is good.
Hi!
Mito-chan good morning!
Good morning!
Good morning Koyu-chan.
Actually okay.
I'm gonna be right back.
Oh my god!
Sorry.
Paz don't do that!
Oh my god she was...Oh my god she was hanging from my curtains.
Okay I'll be right back.
I gotta let her out too.
Dan thank you for the superchat.
Oh my gosh.
I don't have my emotional support cat anymore.
She left.
Oh yeah sorry for everybody who came in and I was going around.
Paz doko she left.
Sorry I'm opening up a box of eyedrops that I got earlier.
I got new eyedrops.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Gone fashion.
Except I forgot to put it up.
I wonder how long this game is.
Oh wait hold on a second.
I got jumpscared by Minto.
Sorry.
Sorry, sorry.
I have something I need to do.
I just gotta check the time.
Oh okay I have lots of time.
I wonder how much we have though.
It's not that long.
Maybe 30 minutes left.
Oh okay perfect.
That's actually great.
Cause then I'm gonna go get some food.
I'm gonna possess somebody.
With a meal.
Mentioned earlier it's a wild year for vtubers.
So I'm good bye.
I was curious what you think the state of vtubing is in.
I don't want to get into it so much.
I'll talk while I'm trying to open up my...
The eyedrops are so difficult to open.
I...
I think...
I don't know how to say...
State of the industry at best.
I think maybe...
In terms of...
Why people might be leaving.
Is that...
No...
People's priorities are changing.
Or people are realizing...
That they can be successful with or without...
You know, some sort of backing.
I think the industry is changing.
I was kind of talking with Matara about it last night too.
How like...
You know, sometimes when...
Someone's oshi graduates.
And then they're just like...
Oh man, I really just miss...
I just miss my oshi so much.
And like...
How do I explain this?
Oh gosh.
It's kind of hard to say.
But like...
For me, I miss my oshis too that have graduated.
But I think...
Because my oshis remind me of a simpler time.
When like, you know...
I was just getting into VTubing or something like that.
So...
Oh gosh, sorry.
I was not prepared at all.
I don't even know why I commented.
Let me get back to my editor.
And then I'll make my formally public...
My formal statement.
Let me get back with my publisher, please.
It is weird how things change.
It's not...
Sweet cheeks.
It's not necessarily like a bad thing.
It's just...
You know, sometimes things will change.
And you'll be like...
Oh, I love this change.
I think I mentioned like...
Nope.
Into the bucket.
I think I mentioned how like...
You know, some people...
I compared it to like a band earlier.
Sometimes a band will like change singers.
Not swingers.
They'll change singers.
You know, and sometimes people are like...
Oh, it's still my favorite band.
They still perform the same song.
They still love it.
But it's also different, you know.
Oh wait, this person I think is good.
Oh wait, check their fingers.
And their toes.
34.
We're good.
But for some people...
A change...
Like something that changes like that...
Do they talk?
Oh my god, they don't talk.
Some people like it.
Some people don't.
I don't know.
Go home.
Okay.
You don't have to tell me twice.
See ya.
Behind that door?
This one?
I think it said behind that door.
That's the bucket I left...
I spilled on the ground and didn't pick up.
Can't wait for your formal opinion on VTubing in the weekly Minto Memo.
Yeah.
Sorry.
I...
Have many thoughts.
It's just that I'm not very articulate.
It's so cold.
Is that what you said?
Oh no.
Give the babies some clothes.
The dolls are cold.
My insight is still appreciated.
I appreciate you appreciating that.
Oh no, my...
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
I would have...
Oh no, I wouldn't have had a thousand dollars.
But that was a lot.
That was good.
950 dollars for one day of work.
And we got all the notes.
Yeah, exactly.
That was good.
There's something different about today.
I can feel the factory even when I'm not there.
It's like it knows I'm coming back.
Like it's been waiting for this.
The dolls...
The dolls.
Those eyes.
They linger in my mind.
Watching.
Always watching.
I don't know why, but it feels like they're waiting for me too.
I thought about not going back, but deep down I know I have no choice.
Something's waiting for me inside and I can't avoid it any longer.
Can we get your official stance on the geopolitical situation?
Of the world and benefits of quantum sci...
What?
The baby dolls.
Run away.
Are you scared yet?
You weren't always like this?
Time to play.
Okay.
Oh no, the locker room is...
Can you fix this?
I can fix you.
Don't worry.
Everything's locked?
Don't let it touch you.
He'll never be alone.
Alright.
Sir, I'm here for my shift.
I'm looking to make about a bajillion bucks today.
Previous error.
Coming back here?
What's this say?
Does anybody read webdings?
Wingdings?
Ding-dongs.
I got my emotional support pet.
Oh my god!
We're still working.
We're kind of crazy.
It says you're dead.
Wait, where?
Where does it say that?
Headless doll, but I can't repair it.
I'll just... Oh wait, what's this say?
Look careful.
All body.
Fingers, fingers.
Factory is watching move.
The webdings.
Oh no way, really?
Freaky!
I can't pick this up.
Or it doesn't budge.
Okay, I'm just doing my job.
Kind of.
Can't really do anything.
I'll just approve it.
Yellow light?
Oh, that's a cactus.
I love that we're still picking these up.
This one is definitely not good, but I can't...
Yeah, I guess we just have to approve all of them.
I'm not getting paid today, am I?
Can I make negative money?
That was very nice.
What did you say?
You can find out.
Well, technically it's like working though.
If you had to say cheesy one quote for a video to promote yourself along the lines of...
What a night... Wait.
Wait.
The cave lion said nothing would jump out at us!
Oh my god.
I'll get back to you, super chat.
I'm kind of going through it, if you couldn't tell.
Now it teaches me how to crouch.
Oh my gosh, it's going to tell us to sprint later too, isn't it?
Where do I go?
I guess forward?
March?
That's a wall.
It says do not let it... They keep saying don't let it touch you.
Is there like something around in here?
Ok, I'm just... I'm hugging the wall.
Oh, here we go.
Oh boy.
Can we get through this?
Ok, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
Walk, walk, walk, walk.
I wish I could run, but I can't.
Oh my gosh.
Walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
Maybe this is what they meant, don't let it touch you.
Oh gosh.
Ok, we made it.
We made it.
Let's turn on the light.
I'm just burning all the babies.
Goodbye little babies.
Nice.
What's over here?
Nothing.
Do I turn off the fire?
Plastic fumes.
Oh yeah, baby.
Smells so good.
Oh, turn off?
Nice.
Oh, requires a valve.
Oh no.
Ok, understandable.
Maybe it's around here.
Gabe, Gabe, where are you?
Gabe.
I was showing Matara some Mega64 videos.
Like the one with Gabe Newell in it.
Oh, there it is.
I found it.
Brings me back.
I know, right?
It was fun watching some of the old ones too.
That I hadn't seen in a while.
Oh shoot.
Ok.
Oh they move but we don't.
Ok, that's fine.
Ok!
I knew it.
You tricked me.
What do you mean by that?
What?
What the?
I like how my task is to perform the quality checks.
Ok, you kind of suck.
Oh, I hear crying.
I think we got betrayed.
Anyway.
I can't see anything.
Oh, there we go.
Oh my gosh, it's parkour jail.
No!
Sad baby!
Don't be so sad baby!
You are no longer alone.
Oh, sad babies!
Nobody puts baby in the corner.
Is this what it made for me?
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
This is crazy.
At least put your feet down.
Poor guy.
These guys are so sad.
Oh my god!
You guys get to stay together.
And they are... I don't know what they are doing.
Mega64 Deus Ex episode had a better story than the game.
What did you say?
Run away?
I'm trying.
I'm working on it I think.
Ok, don't fall maybe.
Look at all these sad, sad little babies.
Oh my god!
No!
Don't do it baby!
The yapping baby.
I shouldn't be laughing.
They are all prisoners.
But I can't.
Their little positions... Oh my goodness.
Their positions are so funny.
The way they are just standing around.
So funny.
Hey what?
Hey is for horses.
This guy is just like...
He is crying and I can't stop laughing.
Side eye baby.
Toy story really went off the rails.
This is what Sid would have created if he had the means and all.
This is Sid's... Oh my god!
He is actually trying to get through there.
Here, take my hand baby.
You have your big old forehead.
You can't stupid.
You can't grab me with your little baby hands.
Your butt is too big to fit through.
There is just something really funny about the guys that are just standing there.
This is what Alice in Toho has to deal with, right?
Can I grab it?
Oh man.
Come on.
Oh there we go.
Nice.
That stuffed doll in his room.
I'm somehow attached to it.
Can't say no to him.
If I would destroy it, I will be free.
Back to back baby.
I know I just sent a super through.
I just realized they can fit through those bars.
They are small enough to fit.
They can just leave.
Not that guy.
He was trying.
Look at him.
Oh my god!
Oh my
baby.
I'm obsessed with seeing what each baby is doing now.
Kill?
Is that what she just said?
Kill.
Oh my god!
This looks like a fresh baby.
Can't say that.
What do you say?
Please help me.
Oh sorry baby.
Oh they are so dramatic.
It's so funny.
Alright.
We drop down again over here.
Now we go around through there.
Oh my god.
These are the freak babies.
These are the real freaks here.
This guy is really... Oh my god.
They are all going through it.
Dance baby!
Dance!
Everyone is so mean to me.
Baby is MVP.
Make it stop.
Why do I feel like I'm gonna get chased though?
Do you think there is anything in these rooms?
Like another note?
I guess I'll check it out.
Just in case.
Kind of invasion of the baby's privacy.
You can hear the gentle...
The gentle sound of his little baby head...
Against the rails.
Look at this guy up here.
What's going on?
No, I'm baby.
I'm baby.
I want what that baby has.
He's not even inside his jail cell.
Just leave baby.
Get out little baby while you can.
Let's leave through the red scary passage.
They look like FNAF animatronics sometimes.
FNAF.
Oh my gosh.
Wow, I almost fell through.
Baby.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my god.
More?
Is the money that he pays you worth it?
Oh my god.
I don't know.
Lay down and cry?
Is that what you said?
Oh my god, there's so many babies.
Now he's ran out of room.
They're shoving him in.
Oh my god, there's so many babies.
They sound kind of slay.
Oh god.
Okay, run, run, run.
Oh my god.
Oh shoot.
I can make it!
I think.
Oh!
I'm in my own jail cell.
Reset.
Oh my god, the gas!
Oh my god, there's gas everywhere.
I'm in baby jail.
I'm a baby!
I'm a dapper baby though.
I hear someone walking.
Time to turn Minto into a marketable doll.
I got ending A.
Doll's life.
Wow!
Ending 1 of 2 is what it says in the corner now.
So I wonder what to do to get ending 2.
Mint baby.
That was so fun.
What happens if I click continue?
Where does it leave me off?
Imagine...
I imagine it...
will...
Let's just try it out.
I imagine...
it leads... lets me continue...
Oh?
I can't get it now.
I don't think so.
I was going to say I imagine it, but I think it just lets you continue at the day you were at.
Gotta restart I think.
That's okay then.
This was still such a...
Funny little game.
There was a prerequisite on an earlier day.
Yeah, I guess don't listen to K or I guess you throw them away or something.
It's my birthday today so I figured I'd celebrate by sending my first superchat to you.
Oh my gosh, Somari!
Thank you!
That's a silly way to celebrate.
You should have spent it on yourself!
And I of course will sing you happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Somari.
Happy birthday!
Yay!
I saw someone say that you have to get something to open up that boarded door.
Which makes sense.
Makes sense, makes sense, makes sense.
That key makes it if I get it.
You need to get a particular note past that door.
That opens it.
Get a crowbar.
For a thousand.
Fun, fun, fun.
Well, maybe if you guys want to see the other ending.
Maybe another Vtuber or streamer will have done it.
Or you can play it yourself.
Very cool.
You find to find a voucher apparently which lets you get an item.
That's cool!
That's fun.
So I guess it does reward you for exploring.
I'm assuming it lets you into the room with the big bash man.
Wait, sorry.
The big boss man.
I was trying to say...
I was going to say the bad boss.
Big boss man's room and then you get the doll and you destroy it.
The bash man.
But this was fun.
It was way...
It wasn't...
I honestly went in with zero expectations but it was cute.
It was fun.
And I liked how they kept adding on to the dolls.
I think maybe it was a little too easy.
I think I was kind of too good at the game.
The only times I messed up was when I was on autopilot.
I was about to say good morning but then I saw it was 4pm.
So good evening, Minto.
Good evening, king.
MintoGamer.
We're gaming.
We made lots of money.
I love that one doll that was like, was the money worth it?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Maybe.
Whatever.
Who cares.
Thanks for the stream.
Did you know in two weeks or today there will be the Phantom Thief concert at the Tabernacle in Atlanta, Georgia.
Yes!
Atlanta, Georgia.
Tabernacle.
Same weekend as Anime Weekend Atlanta but not affiliated with the convention.
But just the same weekend so if you're like, oh I can't travel for just one event, you can travel for multiple events because there's also the Hololive concert.
Which is not conflicting with our concert.
Two weeks.
Two weeks!
Gosh.
There's still so much for me to do.
Oh god.
I'm scared.
I'm nervous.
I'm so nervous.
Oh gosh.
Silly quote time.
Oh yeah!
Silly quote.
If I had to think of a silly quote to describe me...
Oh!
I'm just here for the boobs.
Get it?
Like boo but boobs.
That would be my silly quote.
Sweet cheeks.
I can recommend a plane DLC.
F-15 SMTD.
Since I was playing my Oshi... wait.
My plane is my Oshi too.
I want to see you fly it one day.
Yeah I got all the DLC.
I got like the Top Gun DLC.
Which I actually didn't have before.
So now I have it and I just re-bought the game.
Oh gosh.
Honestly, aren't we all?
Boob.
Boob, boob, boob.
Well guys, this was fun.
Thanks for joining me for Dollmare.
The dolls were so funny.
Oh my gosh, I can't get over how dramatic they were in their little jail cells.
I want to be the most dramatic.
What should we do?
We just got turned into a doll.
What should we do to make our doll so dramatic?
Like suffering.
I like the ones that were kind of just facing the corners.
Somewhere where they had their hands up in the air.
Oh god, why?
Why me?
I bought all the DLC because I love the game a lot.
Walking on the ceiling?
I like the ones with the black light smudges on them.
It's kind of freaky.
Hold your chains out like the Ghost of Christmas Past.
Oh that's good.
That's good.
Make your doll constantly poop and spit.
I don't want that.
A doll.
I had a doll like that.
Don't forget the event Horizon Beat Idol Festival at AWA before the concert.
Oh yeah, I will also be in that.
I will also be in that right before the concert.
Lots of stuff going around.
Lots of stuff.
Stinky doll.
360 head spinning.
I want something that's like... I don't know.
Something that's just so like...
Oh, woe is me.
Oh, I know what I want.
I know what I want.
I want in my jail cell.
You know those like medieval...
I guess it's considered a torture device.
But it's the one where you like stick your head through.
And then you have your wrists through and they're like shackled.
And you just like...
That one where they put you out in town square.
The stalks.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I want my doll to be in the stalks.
And then I'm just in my jail cell like...
I'm in the stalks.
It's so dramatic.
Oh, the fetus and doll in Rita's this week got me thinking of Death Stranding.
Would enjoy watching you stumble into bosses in that game.
I have been thinking about it recently.
Maybe I will give a...
A...
Sorry, I was drawing.
A full shot.
Because I did like playing it before.
I played it before a little bit, but I never finished it.
I was like, I'll finish it off stream, but...
Finishing games off stream is difficult because...
You know, some games have become work for me, right?
So if I'm streaming or if I'm playing a game, I'm just like...
Sometimes feeling like it's work.
So...
Sometimes it's just like...
Makes playing games for fun hard.
I mean, that's quite literally a first world problem.
It's like the...
Oh, woe is me.
I play games all day, so...
When I want to play games for fun, it's just not fun anymore.
Oh, woe is me.
But...
I'm gonna look it up.
Make sure you know what I'm talking about.
Yes!
The pillory.
Yes, yes, a wooden or metal frame with holes for the hands and head.
Public punishment.
Have you ever accidentally commented on a game to chat when playing alone?
I don't think so.
But I have like...
Reacted and been like...
There was something that...
Happened last night.
That I said...
And Matara...
I got a good reaction out of Matara.
And I was like, I'm not even entertaining anybody.
I just...
I just act like that.
I can't remember.
It was silliness though.
Stream Death Stranding with a guest on, though it would be hard to schedule.
True.
Yeah, just freaky like that.
So true.
Is the postcard from the tweet the same art you and Doki signed?
Yeah!
That's the one we signed.
Yes, yes, yes.
I offer this monopoly money in exchange for good times.
Thank you.
So...
I'll think of a way to stream Death Stranding.
I could always just stream it.
I'll get to like part 50.
You know.
There will be two viewers.
Two people that are like, oh man, I can't wait for part 51.
Oh god.
Have you ever had an experience where you bought too many games and you don't want to play any of the games because you can't decide what to play next?
Yes and no.
Sometimes I like have to be in a very specific mood for a game.
Like I want to play Bellatro, but I feel like for some games I have to be in a very specific mood for it.
So...
Thanks for the stream.
I'm taking the JLPT N3 tomorrow.
So this was a much needed break from studying.
Oh my gosh, Paul!
Ganbare!
Good luck.
Break a leg?
Loving the BGM.
Yeah, let's stop listening to the babies.
Let's listen...
Here, I'll put on my own BGM.
Where is it?
Oh, weird.
Ganbare!
Fight on!
O-ensuru yo.
Get that kanji.
You don't need to know stroke order.
But you got this.
Paul-san.
Yeah.
Well, I have some other stuff I'm going to be doing tonight.
So if I see you there, I'll see you.
And if not, tomorrow I'll be playing Made in Akiba...
What is it called?
Made Cafe in Aki...
Electric.
No, not Akiba.
It's not, because it's specifically Osaka.
Made in Electric Street, I think.
So...
Thank you for seven months.
Thank you!
Thanks real bad!
I'm trying to think.
What other stuff?
Oh, I might be making an appearance at somebody's birthday.
Just short.
I gotta go get some food first though.
I gotta get some food first.
So, thank you for stream.
Thank you!
Thank you for watching stream.
Thanks for hanging out with me.
I always appreciate it so much.
Looks so cute.
I was waiting for you to play it.
Wait, what looks cute?
What, what, what?
Before I forget...
Thanks Wall-E!
Wall-E for Space Golly, aka Wall-E for Golly.
Pink Bacon, thank you also for seven months.
Thank you for streaming too!
That's cool!
Okay.
Yeah, okay.
Thank you guys!
What's the main deal?
The maid game.
Oh!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So many people tagged me about it.
Actually, they sent me an email about it.
They were going to give me a code for it.
I don't think it was going to be sponsored, technically.
But, in the end, I responded and then they never responded back.
But, it's funny because another friend gifted it to me instead.
So, another ghostly friend.
So, I was like, no!
It's okay!
The ghost got ghosted.
It's okay.
Like I said, I don't think it was sponsored.
I think they were just wanting to give me the code.
They were like, we saw you commenting.
One game?
Okay.
I'm going to try and not do another horror game.
But, I really want to do that cabin factory game.
Like, I mean, another horror game soon.
But, I think I'm going to try and do my next...
I feel like the cabin factory is very similar to this one.
I want to play the cabin factory.
I'm so excited for that one.
The game looks totally like a Minto game.
Yeah, I'm excited to see what it's all about.
I don't know if we'll beat it.
We'll see.
It's funny because they did ask me not to stream up to a certain point.
But then, they didn't give me the game.
So, do I have to still abide by that?
I'm not quite sure.
I might abide by it just so that I stay in their good graces.
If they ever want to sponsor me in the future or something.
I don't know.
Thank you guys!
Otsubito!
Have a lovely day, a lovely night and I will see you guys next time!
Bye bye!
Otsubito!